Let us analyze the scientific evidence
and the logical reasons why Islam
permits a human being to have non-wage
food. If we analyze the set of teeth of
the herbivorous animal, the cow, the
goat, the sheep that only eat grass and
vegetables, they have a flat set of
teeth. They only eat vegetables. They
don't touch non-veg.
If we analyze the set of teeth of the
carnivorous animal, lion, tiger,
leopard, they have pointed teeth. They
have canine teeth. They're called as
carnivorous animal. A canine set of
teeth. They only have flesh.
They don't touch vegetable. They don't
eat vegetable. If we analyze the set of
teeth of the human beings, if you see
the set of teeth that you have in front
of a mirror, you will find that we have
flat teeth and pointed teeth also. We
have herbivorous set of teeth as well as
carnivorous set of teeth. It is called
as omnivorous set of teeth. So if
almighty god wanted us to have only
vegetables, why did he give us this
pointed teeth? Why did he give us the
canine teeth? If almighty god wanted us
to have only vegetables, why did he give
us the canine teeth, the carnivor set of
teeth? Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala wanted
us to have vegetables as well as
non-vegetables.
When we say non-veg, it doesn't means
only flesh food. Non-veg food means veg
and non-veg mixed together. Veg food
means pure veg, no flesh food. Nonveg
means flesh food and vegetables. So our
creator almighty God gave us both sets
of teeth because he wanted us to have
both vegetables as well as flesh food.
Further if you analyze the digestive
system of the herbivorous animal the cow
the goat the sheep they can only digest
vegetables they cannot digest flesh
food. If we analyze the dasis system of
the carnivorous animal like lion, tiger,
leopard, they can only digest flesh
food. They cannot digest vegetables.
But if we analyze the set of the human
beings, we have a long intestine and a
small intestine.
We can digest vegetables as well as
flesh food. If almighty God wanted us to
have only vegetables, why did he give a
dishes system which can even digest
flesh food? Because he want us to have
it. Furthermore, if we analyze
many of the Hindus,
they think that the religious scriptures
does not permit them to have flesh food.
They think the religious scriptures so
you should only have vegetables. That's
a misconception because most of the
Hindus they don't read the scripture. If
you read the Hindu scriptures, it's
mentioned in Manusmitti chapter number
five verse number 30. It says
that if you eat that which is meant to
be eaten every day, you're not doing a
sin because God created some to be eaten
and some to be eater.
It's further mentioned in Manusmitti
chapter number five verse number 31.
It says that killing an animal in
sacrifice is the law of the gods.
It's mentioned in Manusi chapter number
5 verse number 39 and 40
that killing the sacrificial animal
is not counted as killing.
That means according
to the Hindu scriptures you can have
non-veg food can have flesh food.
And if you read Mahabharat
that's a very famous sacred scripture of
the Hindus
and we know there are five pandawas and
Yudishtir who's the eldest brother he
asks Bishma
his brother that what should we give in
yagna in puja in food
so that the gods will be satisfied.
Hinduism believes in giving food to God.
So he's satisfied. So the elder brother
Yudishtra asked Bishma, "What food
should we give in Jagna in Puja
so that our ancestors will be
satisfied?"
So Bishma replies,
if you give fruits,
barley and rice, our ancestors will be
satisfied for one month. If you give
fish for 2 months, if you give mutton
for 3 months, if you give hair for 4
months, if you give meat of the goat for
5 months, if you give bacon for 6
months, if you give the flesh of birds
for 7 months, if you give veneron,
that's the flesh of the deer for 8
months. If you give ruru for 9 months,
if you give raaya for 10 months, there's
a big menu list of what you can give for
food to the ancestor.
And if you give a buffalo, the ancestors
will be satisfied for 11 months. And if
you give cow beef, the ancestors will be
satisfied for 12 months, one full year.
And if you give a large bull,
they'll be satisfied for 12 years. And
if you give rhinoceros, they'll be
satisfied inexhaustibly.
And it continues that if you give red
meat of the goat also, they will be
satisfied inexhaustibly
forever. There's a big menu given in
Mahabharat Anushasan per chapter 88 on
what food you can give.
It contains all the variety. So the
Hindu scriptures
allows a Hindu to have non-wage food.